l'information de la soirée je vous le
disais au début de cette édition le
député modem jean lassalle propose sa
candidature pour conduire la liste de la
droite et du centre régional en décembre
prochain
nous le retrouvons en duplex de pau dans
un instant mais avant cela patricia
perrin revient sur son parcours d'homme
politique tenace jean lassalle est un
homme politique hors norme à presque 60
ans le 3 mai prochain à l'âge où
certains prennent leur retraite lui se
lance dans un nouveau combat électoral
difficile il est candidat à la
présidence de la future grande région et
se verrait bien à la tête d'une grande
listes d'union allant de l'ump au modem
jean lassalle c'est ce technicien
agricole fils de bergers du béarn et
grand défenseur des causes a priori
perdu en 2003 sur les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale il entame l'hymne
occitan pour attirer l'attention et
sauver une gendarmerie dans sa
circonscription
trois ans plus tard il perd 21 qui l'ont
lors d'une grève de la faim pour éviter
la délocalisation d'une entreprise qui
emploie 150 salariés dans la vallée
d'aspe dernier fait d'armes un tour de
france à pied en 2013 5000 kilomètres
pour prendre le pouls des campagnes
françaises
l'annoncé sa candidature hier lors d'une
réunion en présence d'alain juppé de
jean-pierre raffarin
encore de françois bayrou déjà peut-être
un premier signe d'encouragement à dix
mois du scrutin
bonsoir jean lassalle vous êtes avec
nous en duplex de pau dans les
pyrénées-atlantiques pourquoi faire acte
de candidature au ca d'avoir bientôt
simplement parce que je considère que
c'est une formidable épreuve qui se
présente à nous sur une région qui a été
très décriée maintenant elle existe
toute la question est de savoir si on
veut laisser à l'air ou c'est continuer
ou si on veut changer
moi j'ai envie de changer alors vous
présenter dans quelques adresses que
c'est uniquement au nom du modem ou es
ce que vous avez l'intention de ratisser
relativement large au centre et à droite
le vu large possible et pas concentré à
droite je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de nos
compatriotes il somme perdue aujourd'hui
un gloss et qui ne savent pas où va le
gouvernement et qui n'ont pas très bien
compris non plus ce qui a fait le
sortant d'un ont fait les sortants dans
nos régions précédentes je veux créer un
large rassemblement très proche des
citoyens parce que c'est ce qui le
demandent et qu'il nous signifie
dimanche après dimanche au nom parties
sont mis en déroute et on va le front
national s'envoler jean lassalle est ce
que ça va s que ça ne va pas être un peu
compliqué pour vous face au candidat
alain rousset vous avez perdu contre lui
déjà lors des élections précédentes
élections régionales en 2010 on sait que
le grand sud ouest est une terre de
gauche
oui mais attendez d'abord j'ai perdu
contre lui après un mois et demi
seulement de campagne je suis parti de
3%
je suis arrivé à 17 comme ça je vendais
vous que ce soit d'observateurs se
demander ce qui se serait passé si
j'étais parti mois avant et un petit
village secousses et j'ai l'intention de
créer les conditions d'un large
rassemblement qui prennent en compte les
problèmes quotidiens
les hommes des femmes et les candidats
de toutes sensibilités qui sont
aujourd'hui sur le terrain pour les
élections départementales le voit bien
il ya un ras-le-bol n'ont plus confiance
en nous quant à allah akbar c'est un
très rude comme attac j'ai en face il
est archi favori mais j'aime les défis
et
je suis aussi un compte twitter et si on
a peur d'y aller on n'y va pas monsieur
la salle vous aviez une préférence un
pour une grande région midi pyrénées est
ce que vous pouvez prétendre bien
connaître notre région poitou charentes
1 qui peut prétendre que la connaître
les ans que je laime parce que j'ai vu
que d'excellents souvenirs sur
l'ensemble de votre région et j'y compte
aussi je crois beaucoup d'amis je viens
d'écouter les résultats sportifs et je
vois que c'est une des très grands de
région c'était une des très grands de
région et ce sera une très grande partie
de la nouvelle région en tout cas je
j'ai beaucoup je me sens beaucoup
d'éléments mais de comment je dirais de
fraternité et quand je vois le nombre de
vos concitoyens qui viennent chez nous
et qui parfois même si marie et vice
versa je pense qu'il ya déjà beaucoup de
liens très profonds
monsieur la salle merci d'avoir été en
duplex avec nous depuis pau dans les
pyrénées-atlantiques merci à vous et
très bonne soirée